yes we come to this video
mainz that looks a bit different than
usual because i don't start from
home but am in hamburg in the right
studio and namely at jazz trendy in front of
a website that you are sure to know
has recorded a video series about
spanish a total of 18  share four hours
an overview of the spanish opening
will come out soon whether sexually the before
in the premium member area but
i have another announcement
tomorrow on march 27 at 3 a.m. there will be a
band blitz station in german
first of all chatter blitz i
so will audition on chester mobile
and comment live at the same time
and there will be another session also
in english at 5am so tomorrow some
hours of content with more live the link
is in the description of the video yes
i feel happy if you
guys watch and too  then it will be
trendy check it out when the video series is
out yes I'll say see you tomorrow
when it's time to use it  goes thank you